tense relations between the u.s and
china have dominated a security summit
in singapore over the weekend though the
two sides did sit down for talks chinese
defense minister general wei fang hay
accused his u.s counterpart of hijacking
the support of asia-pacific countries to
turn them against beijing earlier u.s
defense secretary lloyd austin said
china or the prc was causing instability
with its claim to taiwan and increasing
military activity in the region
also stand by our friends as they uphold
their rights
and that's especially important
as a prc adopts a more coercive
and aggressive approach
to its territorial claims
for his part the chinese defense
minister said beijing would be prepared
to invade taiwan in certain
circumstances
if anyone dares to split taiwan from
china
we the chinese army
will not hesitate to go to war
no matter the cost and we will fight to
the end
let's speak now to dr lynn quark a
senior fellow for asia pacific security
at the international institute for
strategic studies she joins me from
singapore welcome to dw news asia
we heard some rather testy comments
there from the chinese and u.s defense
chiefs what's your sense of where this
meeting left ties between the two
countries
thank you for having me jared um i think
first the first point to note is that
this is the first meeting that um
military leaders from the united states
and china
have have had with each other since uh
president biden took office so i think
that's a very positive first step i mean
both sides um exchange testy words but
um i think the fact that there weren't
um fireworks um
was uh encouraging that said um this
must be the first step of many uh steps
necessary to um uh help ameliorate
tensions between the united states and
china and i think broadly speaking what
is more concerning for me is that we're
hearing less and less
from the united states or from china
about their desire to search for common
ground
let's move on and speak about taiwan
because this was also a focus point
we've also heard china made some quite
forceful comments on this issue as did
the us do you think a chinese invasion
of taiwan is more or less likely now
china's calculations will whether to
invade taiwan
would be based primarily on whether or
not it saw itself as able to win
a war
that involved the united states quickly
or at all
the fact that russia has invaded ukraine
is not going to change its calculations
on that matter and i think china's
calculations as i understand it is that
you know it's not it will not be able to
win a war involving the united states
for at least another 10 years so um i
think if anything the war uh
uh in ukraine and how it's panned out
there might make uh china even more
reluctant uh to uh take military action
against uh taiwan in the near to medium
term
i'd like to ask you about the south
china sea which i understand is one of
your areas of expertise and beijing's
disputed claims
china has called for quote turning the
south china sea into a sea of peace
friendship and cooperation do you think
this signifies any kind of a different
approach from beijing
right now what the problem is isn't what
china says it's what china does and what
we've seen in the south china sea is
continued militarization of land
features in the south china sea um we've
seen china continuing its encroachments
into the exclusive economic zones of
coastal states
we've also seen china send
hundreds at times of vessels to surround
features that are occupied
or administered by other countries in
the region now just briefly if you could
relations between australia and china
haven't been great in recent years to
say the least there's a new government
in canberra now
could this be a turning point
um the deputy prime minister of
australia and defense minister of
australia
richard miles spoke at the shangri-la
dialogue i think his words were very
well chosen they were
of a moderate tone um but at the end of
the day australia is going to be taking
a principled approach and it's not going
to be allowing china to exercise um
economic coercion against it as we've
seen china exert in the past and so i'm
not sure that we are likely to see
improvements or relations between
australia and china if china continues
with
actions that are problematic to say the
least uh vis-a-vis australia now if
china were to improve its behaviors
so that it accorded um with uh
principles of international law um so
that it stopped uh
economic coercion against australia
perhaps then we might see
relations improve but i think the ball
in that respect is in china's court
that was dr lin kwok from the
international institute for strategic
studies we really appreciate your
analysis thank you very much